sensibiliser les enfants au spectacle
vivant et les rendre acteurs de ce qu'il
voit c'est ce que propose le festival
festi bouge à bougival pendant une
semaine et demi quatre rendez vous
seront proposés aux enfants dont deux
bilingues français-anglais au programme
théâtre et comédies musicales ça les
aide à grandir c'est à dire que dans
tous les spectacles bien sûr on sort du
quotidien on sort de la vie tous les
jours mais ça nous ramène à la vie de
tous les jours c'est à dire souvent ce
sont des spectacles qui sont en lien
avec un rite initiatique ça les aide à
vivre leurs émotions un jury d'enfants
se rassemblera après chaque
représentation pour parler de la
direction de comédiens des décors de la
mise en scène ont encore de la musique
ça jury constitué d'enfants de
différents âges ce qui veut dire qu'ils
n'ont pas toujours la même grille de
perception la grille de lecture et c'est
intéressant parce qu'en plus c'est sur
des spectacles qui sont complètement
différents donc l'idée c'est pas
tellement de créer un palmarès mais
c'est plus créer un petit peu un
parcours de spectateurs l'école du
spectateur les enfants vont devoir
trouver les forces de chaque pièce et
par là qu'on perd peut pas la
comparaison on va aussi faire émerger
justement la qualité de chacune de ces
pièces le festival débutera le 12 mars
avec un premier spectacle de théâtre
bilingue aliens par la compagnie qu à
l'aco si votre enfant a entre 6 et 12
ans et souhaite constituer le jury vous
avez jusqu'au jeudi 10 mars pour
proposer sa candidature
[Musique]